howdy folks time for another game spot
news update where Microsoft has just
announced the two games they'll be
giving away this month for xbox live
gold subscribers for the first half of
the month you'll be able to download
hitman absolution the latest installment
in agent 47 adventures as the offer
trade assassin while not as celebrated
as fan favorite hitman blood money
absolution was generally well received
by critics scoring a 7.5 from GameSpot
from April sixteenth until the end of
the month Microsoft will also be
offering deadlight tequila works zombie
adventure set across a beautiful 2d
landscape these games are for the Xbox
360 but what about the free xbox one
games Phil Spencer who just today was
announced as the new head of Xbox said
at the beginning of februari that we
would hear more about that soon when
there's news on games for gold for Xbox
one will let you know PlayStation has
already announced their free games for
April PlayStation Plus users will be
getting mercenary Kings for PlayStation
4 batman arkham city and castle of
illusion starring mickey mouse for
playstation 3 and stealth incorporated
velocity ultra and pixel junk monsters
ultimate HD for Vita and as the
competition for free games heats up we
all stand to win be sure to head on over
to gamespot com and subscribe to
gamespot on YouTube for more free game
updates